I'LL JUST SAY THIS FIRST. I'M
NOT GOING TO GET INTO
CONTRACT SPECIFIC, BUT
AARON'S OUR GUY, HE'S GOING
TO BE OUR QUARTERBACK FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE OR EXCITED
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, KIND OF THE
THINGS WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. SO WE
CERTAINLY THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, WITH THE CONTRACT THAT
YOU'RE KIND OF TALKING ABOUT
IS SOMETHING WE'LL WORK
THROUGH. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO PROBABLY A FEW THINGS
WITH DIFFERENT CONTRACTS AS
WE AS WE HEAD TOWARDS THE
SEASON AND THROUGH THE SEASON,
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR SALARY
CAP SITUATION, NOT ONLY THIS
YEAR, BUT IN 2022.
IS SQUARE. SO WE'RE NOT DONE
YET. WE'VE DONE A LOT TO GET
HERE. WE'VE KIND OF BEEN
DOING THINGS AS WE GO AND WE
RYAN GOODYKOONTZ, PACKERS
GENERAL MANAGER. I'D LOVE TO
KNOW HOW MUCH THEY PAID A
CONSULTANT TO COME UP WITH
THE PHRASE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
CHRIS IN THIS CONTEXT. KNOW,
DON'T, YOU KNOW, AND I MEAN
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
CONVERSATION. WE'RE GOING TO
BE A CONVERSATION. WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT A LOT
DURING THE YEAR, I THINK, FOR
BUT YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
SURE. BUT YEAH, I DON'T KNOW,
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. ALL THE
STUFF THERE WAS A LOT OF
THINGS. I QUESTION IN THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE THERE
YESTERDAY
A, YOU KNOW, FIRST OFF GLUTEN
COAST WAS HE WAS HE WAS
HE WAS REELING RIGHT AWAY
WITH THESE CONTRACTS
SITUATIONS AND WASN'T REALLY
A DEFINITIVE ANSWER EITHER.
IT WAS KIND OF LIKE WILL TALK
ABOUT IT. WE GOT TO ADDRESS
IT HERE. HERE'S WHAT I'M
GOING TO ADDRESS WITH YOU
GREEN BAY, YOUR SALARY CAP
SITUATION FOR 2022, WILL BE
BECAUSE AARON RODGERS WON'T
BE THERE. HE'S GONNA BE HUH,
DON'T YOU WORRY, YOU'LL HAVE
PLENTY OF ROOM TO DO ALL THE
THINGS YOU NEED TO KNOW. HE'S
GONE.
IT'S ALL. THIS IS THE LAST
YEAR. AARON RODGERS WILL BE
IN GREEN BAY. I'M CALLING MY
NOW, CHRIS, I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT AT THE CORE THIS IS
ABOUT THE PACKERS PRESERVING
THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE A YEAR
TO YEAR DECISION ON AARON
RODGERS. YEAH. AND AND BY NOT
RESTRUCTURING HIS CONTRACT
YET, THEY PAID HIM IN 6.8
MILLION DOLLAR ROSTER BONUS,
THAT ALL COUNTS TOWARD 2021
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN SPREAD
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS. THEY
STILL HAVEN'T RESTRUCTURED
HIS BASE SALARY, 14 MILLION
IN, CHANGE. THAT COULD BE
SPREAD OVER MULTIPLE YEARS.
COULD BE SPREAD OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS. THE PROBLEM WITH DOING
THAT IS IT MAKES
IT'S THE CAP CHARGE NEXT YEAR,
IF YOU TRADE HIM BEFORE,
JUNE 1 TOO HIGH THE TIES YOUR
HANDS IN 2022. THEY WANT TO
SEE WHAT DOES HE DO IN 21. WE
MAKE A DECISION AFTER 21. IS
HE OUR GUY IN 22? WHAT DOES
HE DO IN 20 TO MAKE A
DECISION AFTER 22? IS HE, OUR
IN 23? THEY WANT THAT
FLEXIBILITY. HE WANTS A
COMMITMENT. IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
HE WANTS MORE THAN A ONE-YEAR
COMMITMENT AND THEY'RE NOT
GIVING IT TO HIM. AND I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO. I
DON'T, I DON'T, I DON'T KNOW
IF I AGREE WITH THAT EITHER.
I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW
SAYANORA SEE YOU LATER, I'M
OUT OF HERE. I DON'T I THINK
THE FLUSTERED OF GUTEN
COOS TALKING ABOUT THE
CONTRACT AND THE EXTENSION
AND WE HAVE OTHER CONTRACTS.
WE GOT TO ADDRESS DURING THE
SEASON FOR ALL THAT. I THINK
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE CALLED
ROGERS AND HIS CAMP AND HAVE
GOTTEN CRICKETS ON THE
RESTRUCTURING THING. BECAUSE
ALL THE REASONS YOU'RE
SAYING GREBE, A WANTS TO DO
ONE YEAR THING ROGERS OF
HERE AFTER ONE YEAR. I DON'T
WANT TO BE TIED HERE. I'M
DONE. I JUST THINK THAT I
FEEL LIKE THE WRITING'S ON
THE WALL THERE. I REALLY FEEL
LIKE THIS IS WHERE IT'S
COMING TO AND I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ANY NEWS
ABOUT THEM. RESTRUCTURE AND
JACK DIDDLY SQUAT, BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
SQUAT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. I
WOULDN'T DISAGREE WITH YOU
THAT THAT'S WHERE HE IS NOW.
YEAH, I THINK BACK IN THE
MIDDLE OF JANUARY, WHEN THE
SEASON ENDED AND HE
GRATUITOUSLY VEERED TOWARD
THAT, HEY, MAYBE I WON'T BE
HERE NEXT YEAR. AND THEN A
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER HE'S
LIKE, WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT,
ALL. BUT WHAT DID I DO THAT?
YEAH. I MEAN HE LIKES HE
LIGHTS THE FUSE BACKS AWAY.
THE BOMB GOES OFF. WE SAY A
BOMB WENT OFF AND WHERE THE
BUTTHOLES ALMOST SAID,
ANOTHER WORD FOR NOTING THAT
THE BOMB WENT OFF. BUT, BUT
I THINK HE THEN AT THAT TIME
WOULD HAVE WELCOMED THE
CERTAINTY. I THINK WE NOW
KNOW WE'RE IN LATE APRIL,
RIGHT? IF HE HASN'T GOTTEN
THE CERTAINLY. NOW HE'S NOT
GETTING THE SIR. THAT'S WHAT
I MEAN. EXACTLY. RIGHT. AND
SO AND SO IT'S ONE MORE YEAR,
RIGHT? AND YEAH, THE PACKERS
AND LOOK. HERE'S HERE'S WHERE
AARON RODGERS HAS TO STEP
OUT OF CHARACTER AND I'LL
BELIEVE THAT HE'S WILLING TO
DO IT WHEN HE DOES IT. HE SAW
WHAT HAPPENED WITH BRETT
FAVRE. YEAH, THEY ENGINEERED.
BRETT FAVRE'S RETIREMENT. NOW
THEY ENGINEERED IT BECAUSE
HE WAS WAFFLING ABOUT IT YEAR
AFTER YEAR. AND THEY FINALLY
DECIDED TO TO NUDGE HIM INTO
RETIREMENT BY ASKING HIM FOR
A DEFINITIVE DECISION IN A
MONTH. WHEN THEY KNEW, HE
WOULD SAY, WELL, IF I HAVE TO
GIVE YOU A DECISION NOW I
RETIRE AND THEN HE TRIED TO
COME BACK. THEY DIDN'T WANT
HIM, THEY WANTED IT.
THE PAGE, THE AARON RODGERS.
HE GOT, HE FORCED TO TRADE,
HE ENDS UP WITH THE JETSONS
WITH THE VIKINGS HE'S PUBLIC
ENEMY. NUMBER ONE IN GREEN
BAY, I THINK AARON RODGERS IS
TRYING TO AVOID THAT. I THINK
AARON RODGERS IS TRYING TO
AVOID THAT. I THINK WHEN THE
TIME COMES FOR HIM TO MAKE
HIS POWER PLAY, HE WANTS TO
BE CERTAIN OR AS CLOSE TO
CERTAIN AS POSSIBLE THAT HE'S
NOT PAINTED AS THE VILLAIN
AND I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW THAT HE CAN PULL THAT
OFF. MAYBE HE CAN MAYBE IF HE
HAS ANOTHER BIG YEAR AND HE
DOES THE PAUL CREWE STICK
THIS IN YOUR TROPHY CASE TO
MARC M
Y OR WHOEVER MAYBE
THE FANS GET BEHIND.
HIM AND HE LEAVES TOWN AS A
CHAMPION AND THE GUY WHO
STUCK IT TO THE ORGANIZATION,
I JUST I THINK THAT'S GOING
TO BE A TOUGH NEEDLE FOR HIM
TO THREAT. YEAH, I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH YOU THERE,
I DON'T, I JUST, I GUESS,
YOU KNOW, IN MY HEART OF
HEARTS FEEL LIKE THAT TIME
HAS COME, YOU KNOW, FOR HIM
TO MAKE THAT TYPE OF TOUGH
DECISION. AND I THINK THE
OTHER ASPECT TO THAT, AT
LEAST IS A LITTLE INTERESTING
THAT I DO NOTICE IS
I FEEL LIKE PUBLIC OPINION
HAS SWAYED TOWARDS ROGERS
FAVOR EVER
IT'S THE NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME A LITTLE BIT TO WHERE I
THINK PEOPLE LOOKED AT IT
WERE LIKE MAN, HE DOES ALL
THESE AWESOME THINGS, MAN.
HE'S AWESOME. CAN SOMEBODY
THERE? HELP HIM A LITTLE BIT?
KNOW, I THINK I THINK A
LITTLE BIT LIKE EVEN THE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LOVE ROGERS.
I THINK CAME AWAY WITH THAT
GAME A LITTLE BIT FEELING.
SORRY FOR ROGERS, FOR MAYBE
THE FIRST TIME EVER. AND I
THINK PEOPLE HAVE ALSO
REALIZED WITH ALL THE TALK
EVER SINCE THE LAST YEAR'S
DRAFT, HOW LITTLE THEY'VE
REALLY DONE TO PUT HIGH-END
TALENT AROUND HIM TO WHERE I
THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION RIGHT
NOW. IF HE DID TO MAKE THAT
TYPE OF MOVE, I THINK MORE A
LOT MORE WOULD FAVOR HIM THAN
GREEN BAY WITH, AT LEAST THE
OPTICS OF THE SITUATION QUICK
POINT, MATT CASEY WHISPERED
SOMETHING IN MY EAR THAT I
WANT TO ADDRESS. TOM BRADY
WAS ABLE TO LEAVE NEW ENGLAND
WITHOUT THE FAN BASE TURNING
ON BUT HE GAVE HIM 20 YEARS,
RIGHT? SIX CHAMPIONSHIPS. AND
IT WAS AT A POINT WHERE BASED
ON WHAT WE SAW IN 2019 YOU
KNOW, THE GAS IS KIND OF OUT
OF THE TANK IF THEY DIDN'T
OWN, A TO KNOW HOW MUCH GAS
WAS TELLING THE TYPE. THEY
MAY HAVE FELT
DIFFERENTLY, WHEN HE WALKED
AWAY, BUT I THINK HE'S
TRANSCENDED THAT POSSIBILITY
OF THE TURN-BASED TURNING ON
HIM IN BOSTON WITH AARON
RODGERS. I DON'T KNOW. AND
AGAIN HE SAW IT HAPPEN WITH
BRETT FAVRE. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT HE'S CONCERNED ABOUT.
YEAH. RIGHT. IT'S A DIFFERENT
SITUAT. IOALN.L  YRIOUGH T' RE
IT